l'élection fédérale a beau être terminée
man les pancartes électorales elles ne
sont toujours pas toutes disparu combien
de temps les verrez vous encore ça
dépend de l'endroit où l'on se trouve
comme van hool expliqué jessica
blackburn un salut au fait des râles ce
sont les municipalités qui détermine
quand les candidats doivent enlever
leurs pancartes une fois les élections
terminées par exemple à saguenay on
demande aux personnes de retirer leurs
affiches électorales dans un délai de 15
jours suivant les élections dans
certaines municipalités c'est beaucoup
plus sévère on donne un délai de 48
heures et pour ceux et celles qui ne
respecteraient pas la réglementation
municipale et bien la municipalité peut
sévir mais c'est quand même assez rare
je vous laisse entendre le porte parole
n'avait le saguenay jeannot allard
on n'a jamais suivi on a déjà eu à
contacter des kansas
par contre après un peu plus de temps
que la normale pour leur rappeler qu'ils
devaient enlever leurs affiches et
plusieurs se demandent qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ses pancartes une fois les
élections terminées
si plusieurs décident de les recycler
d'autres souhaitent ordonné deuxième vie
et c'est le cas de la députée de
jonckeere karinne trudel
entre autres nous avons un apiculteur à
saintes en bois ce qui va aider leur cet
hiver les abeilles vont est isolé avec
mes pancartes électorales et aussi j'en
ai quelques unes qui vont servir à
isoler les cabanes à pêche sont ouverts
qu'on va retrouver sur notre santé
j'ai professeur une fois iem qui me
contactent et de jean-pierre pour avoir
des bancaires pour les projets de son
école pour les jeunes occupants en
terminant les candidats qui nous avons
parlé nous ont assuré que toutes les
pancartes électorales allaient être
enlevées d'ici lundi